all right let's see what is on people's
minds getting to the end of a very very
busy political week we'll go to the
phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
starting today with our caller from the
71 for area code caller from 7 1 4
what's your name where are you calling
from
I've got me yes it is hi David my name
is keiondre I'm calling from the San
Francisco Bay Area how are you good how
are you I'm doing well
it's not a question so I know that the
right
sort of they have this thing where and
you talked about this in your show
before where it's sort of like have
these little quickie responses they can
throw at you you know abortion is murder
and yep blind but we and the left have
to do a lot of explaining well no it's
not because science says you know life
begins here or there and global warming
all we have to do a lot of explaining do
you think the left needs a sort of
rebranding and if you do how so like how
can we be as quickly as quick to respond
to the right and kind of have that level
of just ease of understanding I don't
know that the left needs to rebrand I
think the left needs to become better at
framing and George Lakoff has written
about this a lot and he is actually he
has suggestions about how should the
Left talked about taxes how should the
left talked about things like you know
the musing the military around the world
in the context of how the right views
patriotism and the left news patriotism
there are a lot of really good thinkers
on this issue I don't think it's it's an
issue of rebranding I think it's just an
issue of figuring out better ways to
talk about a lot of this stuff and you
were even seeing it during the
Democratic debates I mean that they're
the candidates are getting better but
take for example this question of should
undocumented immigrants get free health
care it's like when that comes up you
need to be ready to take control of the
question rather than just answering it
in a particular way Elizabeth Warren had
one good instance when she was asked
about you know this should the
government be able to tell you what kind
of straw to use and she didn't accept
the question as asked she said hold on a
second
that's not even the issue the issue is
actually that that is almost completely
insignificant in really dealing with the
issue of pollution and the environment
and the left needs to retake control of
the conversations rather than to food
then fall into what you are correctly
pointing out are often fruitless nuanced
necessary explanations that don't really
appeal to people who are less avid
followers of politics mm-hmm and then
another quick little thing so I also
would like to point out cuz I thought it
was interesting I was just recently
talking to my uncle on my mother's side
and he was in the military and he often
said you know being on the left and the
military is really different because you
can't really speak out because you hear
your military buddies they're all saying
it so lightly and stuff and it's kind of
difficult being on the left in the
military it's kind of viewed as an
American in a way and I thought that was
interesting to point out because I mean
that's what made me think about the
whole rebrand and whatnot yes that is
interesting and I I appreciate you
bringing it up keiondre appreciate
hearing from you all right thank you
okay
very good take care